[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof hello walter hi martin
how are you i'm fine today and you no
good i first have to
see what you're gonna do when i greet
you
to see what i can say next
well it's a game yeah but it's nice game
thank you that's a pleasure let's open
with a word of prayer
our heavenly father thank you
thank you for all the blessings that you
bestow upon us we ask now another
blessing please
that you enlighten our minds with the
holy spirit that this discussion can be
blessed in jesus name amen
amen
so martin
we have decided to talk about
jacob's trouble
and the reason why we are doing that is
because
people want to know what is it going to
be
like and what do we need to prepare for
we've also in the previous episode we've
shown a lot of things that's happening
around the world again yes but what is
the spiritual application to prepare
correct for what is about to come so
what is the application for our time and
why is it important this is a beautiful
typological story
and
jeremiah refers to it
and it's interesting of course that
jeremiah was the prophet
there was there when jerusalem was
destroyed yeah
whenever we talk about the destruction
of jerusalem it always serves as a type
of the end that's it
so jeremiah 307 says alas for that day
is great so that none is like it it is
even the time of jacob's trouble
but he shall be saved out of it
that's a beautiful promise that's it
there's a promise to it there's a
promise but there's also
a
note of
concern yes and this is also an
interesting part that jacob won't be
exempt from the trouble no he will have
to go through the trouble and jacob of
course as we know had a name change
after this event
and that's very important now the one
that will be saved out of it is the one
that underwent the name change that's it
from jacob to israel to israel all right
from a deceiver
to
israel one who wrestled with god
so let's turn to genesis chapter 32.
now jacob was returning
from his exile
and he was on the way home
and jacob went on his way
and the angels of god met him
and when jacob saw them he said this is
god's host and he called the name of
that place
which means two hosts
that's very interesting yeah
and jacob sent messengers before him to
esau his brother
unto the land of say
the country of edom and he commanded
them saying thus shall ye speak unto my
lord esau thy servant jacob says thus
i have sergeant with laban and stayed
there until now
and i have oxen and asses and flocks and
manservants and woman servants and i
have sent to tell my lord
that i may find grace in thy sight
it's interesting that jacob was
greatly blessed in the time of his
sojourn
so we can assume that god's church
will be greatly blessed
to the time of its sergeant yeah
right before the conflict confrontation
yes
if you look at the the advent movement
it is a very
flourishing protestant movement
it has more schools it has more
hospitals than any other protestant
denomination on the face of the earth
it has properties
it has flourished
definitely but there is coming a
confrontation yeah
and the messages returned unto jacob
saying we came to thy brother esau and
also he cometh to meet thee
and 400 men with him
there's trouble
coming it's on the horizon it's on the
horizon and there are 400 men they're
coming from the east they're coming from
the north they're coming from the west
and they're coming from the south
the whole world in other words will be
arrayed against jacob
because the number four is the
number of the earth
compass
yeah the four sides of the compass
then jacob was greatly afraid and
distressed and he divided the people
that was with him into the flocks and
herds and camels
into two bands
it's interesting
there are two bands
and there are all his people yeah
now later on if you go a little bit
further on in history
there will also be two bands
judah and israel
there were two bands
and the one was inclined to be more
prostate than the other
but both of them didn't really perform
exceedingly well
isn't that right that's exactly what
happened yes so you think there might be
two groups within adventism as well yes
those that adhere to the testimony
and the commandments and those that
acknowledge the commandments but don't
have much time for the testimony that's
it do you think it's possible i think
it's possible well typology tells us it
will be like that okay so there will be
two
and verse 10 it says i am not worthy of
the least of all the mercies
because in verse 9 he starts praying and
he says
o god of my father abraham
and god of my father isaac the lord
which says unto me return unto thy
country and to thy kindred and i will
deal well with thee
i am not worthy of the least of all thy
mercies and of all the truth which thou
shalt unto thy servant
for with my staff i passed over this
jordan
and now i am become
two bands
he's become two bands
so he divided them into two groups
deliver me i pray thee from the hand of
my brother from the hand of esau
for i fear him lest he will come and
smite me
and the mother
with the children
so
who's the enemy here
iso
and he's determined to do it right he's
out for revenge
and he's coming to smite him
now he left laban behind
and he left all the nations on the other
side
behind
but his problem
is iso yeah he actually
if we want to put it like that
came out of babylon
yes
and now he's going to face
isa iso
now my problem is
who's is out
today it'll be a brother it's his
brother so it will be a christian
it'll be a christian and so who will be
the one that we might have to confront
the anti-typical esau that's it
apostate christian churches
now when it came to
obedience in terms of marriage
which one of the two sons was obedient
jacob or esau jacob
definitely he wanted to go and he
was looking for a wife and he found a
wife
but unfortunately we're the kinsmen
right that's it unfortunate yes that's a
very important point yes
kinsmen meaning the same faith yes
and then he was
misled he was misled well so it's not
easy it wasn't his choice no but
we are often misled when it comes to
these things but his intention was right
that's it
all right so his intention was right but
isa he went and sought
wives amongst the ishmaelites first the
canaanites then the ishmaelites
and
he was a
a
sorrow to his parents
now the parents in this case we could
equate typologically with god himself
and
esau was the one
who
deliberately took different wives from
different nations
so the anti-typical esau i can expect
that he will have alliances with
different churches
i think the anti-typical esau
loves the economical climate yeah so
previously i said it will be apostate
churches but it will also be apostate
christians yes
so this is what he's meeting in verse 11
it says deliver me i pray thee from the
hand of my brother esau from the hand of
esau for i fear him lest he will come
and smite me and the mother with the
children
and thou says i will surely do the good
and make thy seed as the sand of the sea
which cannot be numbered for multitude
and he lodged there that same night
and took of that which came to his hand
a present for esau his brother
and then it lists this great gift that
he sends before him
and in verse 7 he commanded the foremost
saying when esau my brother meeteth thee
and asked us these saying whose art thou
and whether goest thou and whose are
these before thee
then shalt thou say they be my servant
jacobs it is a presence sent unto my
lord esau and behold also he is behind
us
and so he commanded he the second and
the third all that followed the droves
saying
on this manner shall you speak unto esau
when you find him
and say ye moreover behold thy servant
jacob is behind us
for he said i will appease him with the
present that goes before me
and afterwards i will see his face per
adventure he will accept of me
so here he is sending people ahead to
face esau
first
esau did nothing to them right no
so they were quite safe actually
the one that he was after was jacob
right he had a problem with jacob
so the anti-typical esau
will
face
some that are opposed to him
but his real target is the antitypical
jacob yeah right
he's a real target
and verse 21 so went the present over
before him and himself lodged that night
in the company and he rose up that night
and took his two wives and his two woman
servants and his 11 sons and passed over
the fort jabock
and he took them and sent over the brook
and sent over that he had
and then comes the story that we want to
discuss
and jacob was left alone
and there wrestled a man with him until
the breaking of the day
now that man was none other
than the son of god
yes jesus jesus christ himself
and when he saw that he prevailed not
against him
that's a very important section
when he saw that he prevailed not
against him he touched the hollow of his
thigh and the hollow of jacob's thigh
was out of joint as he wrestled with him
so who saw that he prevailed not against
him jesus
jesus saw that he prevailed not against
jacob
in other words jacob wouldn't let go
standing and he was looking with faith
to that
so the point is actually
that
he was being tested as to his resolve to
cling
and he wrestled until daybreak and he
wouldn't let go
and so jesus saw
that this particular
wrestler
was determined to
stick to the truth right yes
so what does our attitude be
stick to it stick to it don't give up no
there are so many obstacles that will
come our way
and we might think that we have been
rejected because after all this
this is a wrestling match that's it
and it seems as if the one wants to get
rid of you
yes
it seems like it seems like it
very important word we'll get to that it
seems like it
and he said let me go for the day
breaketh and he said i will not let thee
go except thou bless me
now that must be one of the most
important verses in the bible
there must be ah that's it you hear it
in job as well yes lest he slay me i'll
still serve him even if he slay me
i will not let you go
except you bless me
now what did he touch
and put out of joint his hip
the hip right
now is there
what is the importance of the hip
for walking
for walking all right you need to be
able to walk but the hip is also the
pivot that determines your direction
now he was going to walk with a limp
he wasn't going to walk like he wanted
to before
he was going to be handicapped
and the handicap was to be a blessing to
him
mull that one over yes i can already see
it's the road
it's not going to be easy it's not going
to be easy we're going to get there
limping that's it
and you're not going to be
walking as you would like to walk all
right so if you are limping and if you
have this infirmity
do you then become more dependent
yes
is it possible to run away quickly no
no right
you're pretty dependent yeah you have a
problem
and he said unto him what is thy name
and he said
jacob
and he said thy name shall be called no
more jacob
but israel
and israel means a prince of god
for as a princeton has power with god
and with men and has
prevailed
and jacob asked him and said tell me i
pray thee thy name and he said wherefore
is it that thou dost ask after my name
and he blessed him there
so did he tell him the name no
no he didn't tell him the name
but he did tell him that he had wrestled
with god yes
so actually
he knew he knew who he was and also in
the previous one that israel the name is
a prince that has power with god as
power not on your own this road that you
will walk limping
it will only be
able with god yes you will only be
enabled with god and japan called the
name of the place pineal
for i have seen god face to face and my
life is preserved
pineal means the face of god
now if we look ahead a little bit
moses did he see the face of god
no
no he was you could only see him from
behind right and he had to even then be
hid in the cleft of the rock
but
jacob says he saw the face of god
that means he saw the righteousness
of christ
and he perceived his character
and he knew he had to change so when you
see the face of god you can see the
righteousness and you see
at the same time by contrast your
wretchedness
and as he passed over penuel the sun
rose upon him and he halted upon his
his thigh
therefore the children of israel eat not
of the sinew which shrank
which is upon the hollow of the thigh
and to this day because he touched the
hollow of jacob's thigh
in the sinew
that shrank
so from this time forward
he had to
walk in dependence
not independent but in
dependent yes he had to be
dependent
and
why was he wrestling and what was he
wrestling about
it was all about
is my sin forgiven
it was about his sin
so with that little introduction
we can turn to jeremiah chapter 30 verse
7 again
and we are told by jeremiah
for that day is great so that none is
like it it is even the time of jacob's
trouble
but he shall be saved out of it and we
have to look at that promise
and we have to look at the condition
for that promise
spiritual gifts volume 3 page 1 28 and
21 29
jacob's wrong
in receiving his brother's blessing by
fraud
is again brought forcibly before him
and he is afraid that god will permit
esau to take his life in his distress he
prayed to god all night
he pleads that he has deeply repented of
his sins
and the wrongs against his brother
which have been the means of separating
him from his father's house for 20 years
the angel seemed to be resisting his
prayer by continually calling his sins
to his remembrance
and at the same time endeavoring to
break away from him
in his distress jacob referred to the
repentance of his soul the deep humility
had felt for his wrongs
and the angel regarded his prayer
with seeming indifference continually
making efforts to release himself from
the grasp of jacob
all right so there we have a little bit
more insight as to what was going on
and what was running through his mind
right yes and this wrestling now if you
pull it through
to
typologically our time
obviously it means that god will bring
to remembrance
some
past
happenings in your life
to let you think have i really put this
repentance forward yes
now you're still
quite young
relatively speaking when you compare
yourself to me for example
and
i can i can tell you that
as you get older
some of the things that
come up
in your thinking
about your past
are pretty
pretty troubling
yeah true and you say to yourself
why why did i do such stupid things how
could i have been so stupid
and you wrestle about it and you have to
accept
by faith that god has forgiven them
now
it says there that he had received the
blessing by fraud
now
it was fraudulent of him that he took it
into his own hands to receive the
blessing
basically that is salvation by works
that's true
did he have a promise that he would get
the blessing yes he had a promise that
he could get the blessing he didn't see
the way open
by any
particular
way in which this could happen because
it was totally opposed to
the laws of the time as to who should
receive the blessing the firstborn right
so here was a problem
and so he decided to help god that's it
okay
is that something that the religious
world is very inclined to do yes
so help god definitely especially with
sorting out earth's problems
yes now what's very ironical
is that
of the two esau and jacob
was one of them immune from this or did
isa also tried to
do it his way yeah no definitely in fact
iso
always tried to do it this way he never
went repentant to god to say sorry for
it and jacob at least tried to do it
god's way
but thought he had to help god right do
we have a similar problem you can also
find the stories to the bible abraham
had the same problem it's human nature
right
so basically what we are dealing with in
essence here
is righteousness by works as opposed to
righteousness by faith that's it
and the only ones that can really
wrestle with god
and not let go
are the ones that they
that realize that all their attempts
were fraudulent
that's
exactly how it is and therefore the only
only thing that you can cling to
is growth that's it
you can only cling to that and you have
to cling to that grace by faith
all right and then you have to repent
now martin i'm going to ask you a funny
question now
does that perhaps mean that you even
have to repent of your good works yes if
you that was a means to try and save
yourself ah
in other words god is not against your
good works because good works are a
fruit that's supposed to develop on a
good tree but if your good works had an
ulterior motive
if you think that you could twist the
arm of god
by introducing
a methodology or whatever to twist his
arm
then you have to repent of that too
because nothing in my hand i bring
simply to the cross i cling absolutely
okay so basically this is salvation by
works two religious systems
clashing
and jacob is the one that wrestles with
god
and won't let go
so he's the one that realizes
that his only means of salvation is
absolute dependence
the sequence must be
right so how much of self was left
zero
so in his distress he referred to his
repentance of of his soul
the kingdom of heaven is at hand
repent
is the first word that then came out of
jesus's mouth
or out of the mouth of any of his
prophets
including john or any one of them that's
it
repent
without repentance it is impossible to
enter the kingdom of heaven
and it's so beautiful because that
repent makes you totally dependent on
jesus and not yourself
correct
now once you repent you turn around and
you go the opposite direction
but jacob would not give up his earnest
efforts for bodily pain
his object was to obtain a blessing and
pain of body was not sufficient to
divert his mind from his object
let's just stop there
does it seem strange
that god's people are often afflicted
even bodily
no and i think even
looking at the future
when
taking the past as an example
there might be physical pain also
attached to it in the future there might
be there certainly will be spiritual
pain but physical pain
you might have to
bear that as well and people might think
but why why would god permit this right
why should i have this or that infirmity
it's actually the wrong question
why should i not have it yeah
why should everybody else be subject to
it and and
not i why did jesus have to go through
it and die and not i
his determination was stronger in the
last moments of the conflict than at the
beginning that's also very interesting
you know you have to read these things
carefully amazing
he actually grew in faith while
wrestling while wrestling okay
so sometimes we have to wrestle and we
can grow in faith
i don't know about you but sometimes if
i can't sleep
i seem to be wrestling
that's it your mind's wrestling the
whole time and it usually happens about
half past one in the morning
[Laughter]
his faith grew more earnest than
persevering that's the next point right
until the very last even till the
breaking of the day he could not let go
his hold of the angel until he blessed
him and he said
let me go for the day breaketh
and he said i will not let thee go
except thou bless me
and the angel then inquired what is thy
name and he said jacob and he said thy
name shall be called no more jacob but
israel
for as a prince there has power with god
and with men and has
prevailed
so because he wrestled with god and
would not let go and met all of those
conditions
he was called israel yeah
so anti-typically who is israel
the children of god anyone who wrestles
with god the righteousness prevails
the righteous and you how can you become
righteous only by appropriating the
righteousness of christ that's it you
cannot it's not your righteousness
actually
so he held fast the angel until he
obtained the blessing he desired and the
assurance of pardon of his sins
now you highlighted the assurance of
pardon
of his
sins if you confess your sins
he is faith he is faithful
right that's it and he will cleanse you
from how much of your unrighteousness
all
all of it
now
martin are the essence that you have
committed that you might not even
remember definitely
so how do you deal with that
can we turn to psalms
you know this is actually a beautiful
psalm
the heavens declare the glory of god and
the firmament showeth his handiwork
now there you have hebrew parallelism
the heavens and the firmament right
and they declare the glory of god that
means they declare the character of god
if you want to know something about the
character of god
then line your back on a starry night
and look up at the firmament
day and today utterance speech night and
tonight showeth knowledge
you see
he doubles up everything
he always has these two that speak
two witnesses
there's no speech nor language where
their voice is not heard their line is
gone out through all the earth
and their words to the end of the world
in them has he set a tabernacle for the
sun
now martin this is a very interesting
astronomical lesson that we are reading
about here
and then in verse 5 it says
which is as a bridegroom coming out of
his chamber
and rejoices as a strong man to run a
race so basically what he's doing
is going from the glories of the created
world
and say they are a witness
to the character of god
but that's not enough
it's not enough if the inanimate world
testifies of the glory of god because
there are many people in this world
martin
that
love nature yes
that are nature freaks
that are greenies
but they might be very far removed from
god
exactly
they acknowledge the magnificence
but they don't acknowledge the creator
and they don't acknowledge the
conditions
so now we go to
the definition of the rest
so we have a perfect creator creation
but there must be
and more
talks about the sun he's going forth is
from the end of the heaven and his
circuit unto the ends of it
and there's nothing hid from the heat
thereof
so he's talking about the inanimate
creation and then he turns to
another witness
the law
of the lord
is perfect
converting the soul the testimony of the
lord is sure making wise the simple to
the law and to the testimony testimony
all right so you have the inanimate
world
and maybe even the animated world the
animals and everything testifying to the
glory of god but now you have another
witness which is the law and the
testimony
the statutes of the lord are right
rejoicing the heart the commandments of
the lord is pure and enlightening the
eyes
the fear of the lord is clean enduring
forever the judgments of the lord are
true and righteous all together more to
be desired are they than gold yay than
much fine gold sweeter also than honey
and
the honeycomb
so here you have a description
of the glory of the law and the
testimony
and the and the basis of the government
of god and
the heart of the principles of judgment
right that's it so we have these two
great witnesses
and then it comes
to something very interesting
verse 11
moreover
by them
by the law and the testimony the
statutes the commandments all of these
things
thy servant
is warned
and in keeping them
there is great reward
so it's not enough to love nature
you must love the law and the testimony
you must love the commandments
and then you have to keep them yes
it's a it's a constant theme throughout
the bible and if anybody tries to
eliminate it from the bible you have a
problem right
then come these interesting verses why i
wanted to refer to psalms 19 in the
first place
keep back thy servant also from
presumptuous sins
keep back thy servant from presumptuous
sins in other words prevent me from
arrogantly going ahead and doing what i
know is wrong because i've been warned
in your word and in the testimony that
that is not the right way to go
and if we want to pull it through to the
remnant the the testimony of the
prophetic insight has continued in the
remnant because the remnant must have
the testimony as well
and anything that is written there and
you presumptuously ignore it
makes you guilty that's it
now is that a problem in the remnant
definitely
it's a big problem and the thing is this
presumption
you think you are sometimes correct
and you're doing god a favor
that's a big part of this presumption
yes so
there are two groups within the remnant
as well
those that
think that the testimonies are binding
and are a
image of the will of god
and those that think that they are of
human devising
two groups that's it
there are also two groups in jacob's
little group
all right so keep back your servant from
presumptuous sins that is keep me from
doing
what i know
is wrong
let them not have dominion over me
then shall i be upright and i shall be
innocent from great transgression
so that's the first condition
if you know something is right if
something has been revealed in the law
and the testimony and you do not do it
then it be for you sin yeah
now let me just backtrack here martin
let's go
back to verse 11.
moreover by them thy servant is warned
right
by the precepts
and in keeping them there is great
reward we've dealt with that
now this is interesting verse 12 who can
understand his errors
cleanse thou me from
secret faults
who can understand these errors martin
we are so fallen
that we do not even know the depth of
our condition no that's it we don't know
and actually we might think that we are
actually quite the bee's knees on
occasion
and we do not even know that we are
blind pitiful and wretched right
therefore god has built this into his
program and he says
cleanse thou me from secret faults
some translations will take this word
secret and say hidden faults
some that i do not even know about
keep back thy servant from presumptuous
sins
let them not have dominion over me so
there are two categories here that are
mentioned
those that i am aware of
where i would willfully sin and that
would be presumption
and those that i'm not even aware of
but that god can make me
aware of
over time yeah
and i realized
i thought that was so so great but
actually it's not so great right
and you have to repent of both
and you have to repent of both so does
god forgive even that that you do not
know
yes
but when he reveals it to you and you
break it yeah then it becomes a
presumptuous sin
now once
that condition has been met or these
conditions have been met
then you will be innocent from great
trans transgression and let the words of
my mouth and the meditations of my heart
be acceptable in thy sight o lord
my strength and my redeemer so here you
have
both justification
and sanctification
without justification
you would be in trouble
without sanctification you will not see
god
exactly so if you go to this
the assurance of the pardon of his sins
when
that states that you've got even hidden
sins yes
repent of that
and ask god
and then when he shows you
still repent and turn away from it yes
now when you get to my age martin
you'll finally be totally without defect
do you believe that
no
you don't believe it
okay
so let's not even go there
so let's prayerfully like jacob just
cling
refuse to let go
unless he bless you
and let's stay away from presumptuous
sins
and let's ask god to cleanse us from
all
unrighteousness that's it
the thing is that no unrepentant sins
can be forgiven
no you have to repent of all your sins
and you must realize
that
sin is abhorrent
and the wages of sin is death
eternal death yes that is so you've
we've got a chance
today
to repent of our sins
and remember that it will be a
continuous thing right up until we see
jesus and it is given for man once to
die
and thereafter the judgment
so there's no second chances anywhere
according to the scriptures so if you
want to get this right you have to do it
now
if we continue the story it was christ
that was with jacob through that night
with whom he wrestled and whom he
perseveringly held until he blessed him
he did not sanction any wrong course
which jacob pursued
his life was one of doubt perplexity and
remorse
because of his sin until his earnest
wrestling with the angel
and the evidence he there obtained that
god had pardoned his sins
esau was marching against jacob with an
army for the purpose of killing his
brother
but while jacob was wrestling with the
angel that night another angel was sent
to move upon the heart of esau in his
sleeping hours
and in his dream he saw jacob in exile
from his father's house for 20 years
because he was afraid of his life
and he marked his sorrow to find his
mother
dead
he saw in his dream jacob's humility
and angels of god around about him and
he dreamed that when they met he had no
mind to harm him
and when isa awoke he related to his 400
men his dream and told them that they
must not injure jacob
for the god of his father was with him
and when they should meet jacob not one
of them should do him harm
now
what were the circumstances that
compelled esau not to harm his brother
the intercession of angels
ah the intercession of angels it wasn't
a character change no
and that's important that we understand
it so god
will preserve his people
even in the face of the fact that there
is no repentance
in the heart of the anti-typical isle
that's it it will be the intercession of
angels that preserves the anti-typical
jacob
that this brings to mind also that verse
that says
when god is with you
who can stand against you yes these
angels will go
forward now some people might interpret
this
well
esau had a change of heart therefore
let's go into economical relations with
esau the answer is no because esau
never repented
jacob i loved but esau i hate him
now he never hated esau he hated what
esau did he hated what he stood for
so jacob and esau represent two classes
we've seen two classes
right through the story right and we've
also seen two classes inside of jacob
correct
jacob the righteous and esau the wicked
jacob's distress when he learned that
esau was marching against him with 400
men represents the trouble of the
righteous
as the decree goes forth to put them to
death just before the coming of the lord
martin if it weren't for these
typological studies
the bible would be a dead letter
and you won't what will you be able to
cling on
for hope in this time that we're going
towards the bible must become
alive it must be applicable to your time
every single one of these stories
must be seen in a typological light
as the wicked gathered about them
they will be filled with anguish for
like jacob they can see no escape for
their lives
the angel placed him before jacob and he
took hold of the angel and held him and
wrestled with him all night so also will
the righteous in their time of trouble
and anguish
wrestle in prayer with god as jacob
wrestled with the angel
jacob in his distress prayed all night
for the deliverance from the hand of
esau
the righteous in their mental anguish
will cry to god day and night for
deliverance from the hand of the wicked
who surround them
we are now heading for that time of
trouble everybody can see the walls
closing in you see
esau on the horizon isa is coming
and he's coming from the north and he's
coming from the south and he's coming
from the east and he's coming from the
west and he has one intention
and that is to get rid of you
and
everything that belongs to you he wants
to get
rid of you
now
the solution is to wrestle with the
angel
and to leave the consequences
to god to god now
question
could he not have turned and run yes he
could he could have run away right
but he didn't no
would he have repented if he ran away no
no so where's he going he's going for a
confrontation
so is there iceberg ahead
are we going to have to meet it yes is
there any turning around no
and are you going to go with your
strength or are you going to be
handicapped and limping no it will be
limping because
you cannot do it on your own you're
gonna have to grab hold
of the angel of jesus you have
absolutely no defense nothing you're
absolutely helpless
that's not a condition that man likes to
be in but if we are not in that
condition we will not prevail
so let's have a look at the condition
that we must have in this time
and we're talking about now in case in
case people don't understand what we're
talking about we're talking about
now
because esau is on his way that's it
the righteous in their distress will
have a deep sense of their unworthiness
in other words no one will say no one
will say i have arrived no
it's so important because we have to
realize our utter and
complete dependence on gay on jesus
and with many tears will acknowledge
their utter unworthiness
and like jacob jacob will plead the
promises of god through christ made to
just such dependent helpless repenting
sinners this is not a natural condition
that we would strive for
but it is absolutely essential
it has to be
such that you are totally emptied of
self was there anything that jacob
withheld
from jesus when he was
wrestling with him no he was he was
confessing his faults if all of it and
in spite of it he wouldn't let go that's
it
because that's his only hope it's like
it's like you're in the ocean
you're sinking in the quagmire somebody
throws you a lifeline
and no matter what you're not going to
let go because you know the moment you
let go you're going to be dead and at
the same time you this grasp that you've
got there you don't let go but you have
to let go of all the other things that's
going to pull you down you have to let
it go you're right so that that road is
very narrow
and it's not broad enough to take your
baggage with you nothing you have to
throw and pride and all of that also
becomes baggage
jacob took firm hold of the angel in his
distress and would not let him go as he
made supplication with tears
the angel reminded him of his past
wrongs
it's an interesting point right that's
god will bring to remembrance that which
you have done
and you will have to repent
and endeavor to escape from jacob to
test him and prove him and so will the
righteous and the day of their anguish
be tested proved and tried to manifest
their strength of faith their
perseverance and unshaken confidence and
the power of god to deliver them
you have to be put into the crucible
and subjected to the fire
yeah
and you have to
buy
gold refined in the fire but from god
absolutely
god would not have heard the prayer of
jacob and mercifully saved his life
if he had not previously repented to his
wrongs in obtaining the blessing by
fraud
so martin some people say well i'll do
it then
or wait till the death bed and maybe
that will work
no you have to
[Music]
you have to realize you were wrong and
you have to repent before you get to
this point you have to do it
right now
so this is actually
like an investigation that's it
it's like an investigation is this
repentance genuine
and i'm going to tell you i don't think
it's genuine enough and i'm going to
push you away
it's not good enough you didn't do it
good enough and you just cling and you
say that's all i have
i can do no other
okay so the righteous like jacob
will manifest unyielding faith and
earnest attempt determination which will
take no denial
they will feel their unworthiness
but will have no concealed wrongs to
reveal
if they had sins
unconfessed and unrepented of
to appear then before them
while tortured with fear and anguish
with the lively sense of all their
unworthiness they would be overwhelmed
so how important is it that we make a
thorough investigation as to our
condition it is paramount and this has
to happen now
because like we've just read and the
whole typology of this jacob wrestling
with the angel is telling us
this has to be done now because there's
no time to do all of this when that big
trouble hits all right now martin what
if
the sins of such a nature
that you might actually think they were
righteous
god will have to help you in
showing you that it was not
what if you have for example
evil surmisings
what if you are looking at your brothers
and sisters
and finding fault
and by comparison
you're actually lifting yourself higher
than they
need that be repented it has to because
that forms part of the baggage
that you cannot carry with
when you're clinging to god when you see
your brother doing something wrong
many are inclined to automatically
elevate themselves because they are not
doing that wrong
it would be better to remember where we
came from
rather than to compare ourselves among
ourselves because those that do that
according to the scriptures are not wise
was jacob here wrestling about other
people's
sins or about his own that's a very good
point that you have mentioned there
so
we should not have a comparative
wrestling
comparative wrestling says ah but lord
i'm not as bad as this one or that one
so this is a very serious issue
so he has a very lively sense of his
unworthiness you know martin
this sort of flies in the face of
perfectionism doesn't it
you see that's exactly because when you
go to perfectionism or any of these
it once again shows to you and not to
god yes that's a comparison it's a
comparing yourself among yourselves and
those that do this are not wise
according to the scriptures
despair would cut off their earnest
faith and they could not have confidence
to plead with god thus earnestly for
deliverance and their precious moments
would be spent in confessing hitting
sins and bewailing their hopeless
condition
those professed believers who come up to
the time of trouble unprepared will in
their despair
confess their sins before
all in words of burning anguish
while the wicked exult over their
distress
the case of all such is hopeless
this is like
the foolish virgins
they woke up too late there were also
two groups that's six the wise and the
foolish
so within god's church you have both of
these
and i think it would be better to decide
now in which category
we would want to
which category we would want to belong
to right
so when christ stands up
and leaves the most holy place then the
time of trouble commences and the case
of every soul is decided and there will
be no atoning blood to cleanse from sin
and pollution
so the time of repentance
is now now
but please remember that repentance is a
very personal thing
it has to do with yourself
the wrestling is between you and
god so any form of
collective repentance
will not wash because it has to be a
deep-felt personal repentance individual
depend uh repentance yeah if you cannot
be saved in cooperation
so as jesus leaves the most holy place
he speaks in terms of decision and
kingly authority
he that is unjust let him be unjustly
and he which is filthy let him be filthy
still and he that is righteous let him
be righteous still and he that is holy
let him be holy still and behold i come
quickly and my reward is with me to give
every man according to his work shall be
this clearly shows us that probation
closes before christ comes
yes it's before he comes and the
judgment will be complete when he comes
so we'll be in the big time of trouble
the plagues will be falling
and
we will still be in jacob's trouble
that's it because esau is coming to kill
us remember that the death decree
goes out towards the end of this process
and not the beginning of this process
first there is buying and selling
economic measures ridicule everything
that goes with it and eventually a death
decree
and those who have delayed a preparation
for the day of god cannot obtain it in
the time of trouble
or at any future period the righteous
will not cease their earnest agonizing
cries for deliverance they cannot bring
to mind any particular sins but in their
whole life they can see but little good
it's also another important thing
if you belong to this category that the
bible here calls the righteous
they never get to a point where they
think that they have arrived or achieved
something right no they continually even
if you can't they say yeah even if you
can't remember that sins
and that's what will happen and that's
why so important the repentance has to
go on from today now
now absolutely essential
their sins had gone beforehand to
judgment and pardon had been written
their sins had been born away into the
land of forgetfulness and they could not
bring them to remembrance certain
destruction threatens them
and like jacob they will not suffer
their faith to grow weak because their
prayers are not immediately answered
we are going for that time of trouble
right
now
we are on our way on a speed train
towards it
though suffering the pangs of hunger
they will not cease their intercessions
the season of distress and anguish will
require an effort of earnestness and
determined faith that can endure delay
and hunger
and will not fail under weakness
though severely tried the period of
probation is the time granted to all to
prepare for the day of god
if any neglect the preparation
and heed not the faithful warnings given
they will be without excuse
now martin
as we read in psalms 19
the law
and the testimonies
we have to
beware of presumption
so if god has revealed his will
and we neglect
to do his will then we are guilty let me
ask you another question i'm going to be
the devil's advocate here mean
suppose i
neglect to read
the admonishments
am i then also guilty definitely because
how would they know what god
might reveal to you
now even in this world
is ignorance of the law an excuse for
breaking the law unfortunately no
even in this unrighteous world ignorance
of the law is no excuse for breaking the
law
so my question is ignorance
of what god has revealed
is that not also
a way to petition it is
you cannot use an excuse to tell god no
sorry i have been too busy i didn't get
time
all right so if got if you call yourself
a christian
and if you call yourself a commandment
keeping christian and if you believe in
the law and the testimony
would you they not want to study the law
and the test you have to
you cannot do any other it's like you
because if you don't study it
that one in psalms 19 that says
presumption
you might be under presumption because
you've not studied and god could not
reveal anything to you because you're
using your own thoughts now i just read
in the spirit of prophecy
i just read it last night
i read that there
will be those that ignore the
testimonies to their peril
and that those who study them and take
them to heart
will be preserved from all
the false ideologies
and
doctrines and ideas that are coming in
like a flood
so it's very important that we
understand these things and also this
set
there is
a
preparation we are in the preparation i
was just thinking
the time that we're living in now
is like a friday before the sabbath this
is preparation day yes but it's going to
be hard because with a sabbath the rest
of a thousand years will be coming
why there is so little exercise of true
faith and so little of the weight of
truth resting upon
many professed believers is because they
are indolent in spiritual things that's
exactly what we were just talking about
indolent that means you're lazy you
don't want to do it
so you don't do it you have the
testimonies they might be on your shelf
but you won't read them
and even if they're not on yourself
it's a click away they're in their in
your computer you can read them they're
on the web
you don't even have to buy them
england is also oh it's a bit
uncomfortable i'm not gonna
i don't want to i don't want to yes
laziness
they are unwilling to make exertions to
deny self to agonize before god to pray
long and earnestly for the blessing
and therefore they do not obtain it
you know repetition in prayer is often
made a condition
to receiving an answer not because god
wants to be vindictive
but because he's testing your faith
working on you it's for yourself it's
not yes and sometimes we have to work
out
am i wrestling for my will
or am i wrestling for god's will
because sometimes if i want an answer
i must be able to accept that no
is also an answer that's a 100
yes and sometimes you can be doing or
think you're doing
something for god
but then you can actually be working
against him yes because of your lack of
study
so that faith which will live through
the time of trouble must be in daily
exercise now
those who do not make strong efforts now
to exercise persevering faith will be
wholly unprepared to exercise that faith
which will enable them to stand in the
day of trouble so you must be able to
endure trials you must be able to endure
waiting you see in the previous
slide there was also mentioning of
hunger
and
that can be physical as well
we'll get this time of trouble will be
such as the world has never seen
so what is our duty
to prepare for it now yes
but if you do this the bible promises
that he who has done a good work in you
will certainly bring it to fruition to
fruition and to completion
so martin
this is basically a summary of what it
means to go through jacob's trouble
where we are in the stream of time today
it's also a warning
lest we become presumptuous
unless we think that we are something
special
the closer you come to christ the more
unworthy you will feel in your own eyes
now that doesn't mean that you are
useless it just means that you have
realized where your strength comes from
your total dependence yes
nothing it doesn't make you worthless
because christ was prepared to die for
you
but there's another statement that that
i've read in the spirit of prophecy
which which i often
referred to
and it says the sheer effort
it takes to come back
is the greatest evidence of how far
we have fallen
the difference between what god's
original intention for humanity was and
what we have become over 6 000 years of
sin
or let's say
almost 6 000 years of sin
show us exactly what state we are in
and it is only
by repentance and total reliance and
dependence that we can be saved amen
let's pray
heavenly father
this story about jacob's trouble
is a story that affects all of us
because no one is exempt from it
and as we
approach this time
i pray that you will give us the courage
and the resilience not to let go
even if our hips be put out of joint is
my prayer in jesus name
amen amen
[Music]
so
you